Prince Harry and his fiancee Megan Marco
went on their second official royal
outing together the couple visited a
radio station for young people yesterday
it is in the multicultural neighborhood
of Brixton in South London Charlie
d'Agata was there as hundreds of
well-wishers welcomed the royal couple
that famous British reserve
was nowhere to be seen on the streets of
Brixton South London especially when
Prince Harry asked fiance Megan to turn
to the crowd and once inside the prince
was just as charming represent radio was
set up in part to counter a rise in
knife crime among young people why did
you want to come out today to see them
came out I came out doing my shopping
and I found out about it so I decided to
just stop around another look but this
wasn't just about making an inner-city
public appearance Prince Harry and Megan
Markel are here to show their support
for a program that aims to help those
struggling with mental health issues and
helps keep youngsters off the streets
but it's those living on the streets
that's caused controversy after local
leader Simon Dudley suggested police
should clear the homeless outside
Windsor Castle before the royal wedding
it's a situation that has to be resolved
the royal couple have already made clear
they want their wedding celebrations to
extend well beyond those castle walls
for CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata
London people gaga over the Royals in
the crowd a radio DJ handed him a card
and said I can play at your wedding
which i think is very bold very bald you
want to avoid the wedding bands no
feelings nothing more than feelings so
happy for them both